Regina how do you see the cultural
importance of the best man franchise
both now and when it was first released
how do you see that
um well you know I I I mean I think
movies always have
um you know you make a movie and then
there are a lot of other movies like it
and I think for me for me as just as a
viewer to watch
these friends who were in their 20s who
were at uh who were close friends in
college very yeah younger yeah 20 20.
who wouldn't their teens no but who had
varied
um success and friendship was really
beautiful marriage I mean you had a
football star marrying a college
sweetheart you had an incredible like
well producer right well no I was gonna
I was the side piece let's be real no no
his heart was there his heart was there
but his heart was there but doesn't mean
you can't be the side piece and have
heart you were more than a size but I
was
even nice yeah
he's talking about real life we're
talking about Jordan
That Got Away yeah
okay well it's it's however you want to
color the picture yes yeah keep going
okay okay so we had you know well Uber's
successful side pieces yes
probably not probably not today
but I think it was it was important for
me to see that and I think it was
important for that to be out there in
the world yes you know Regina were you
in the first yeah
Regina was a stripper hit him
if she was in the face
you're the stripper
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]